Okay.
This is really important.
The Trump administration has documents showing
they know how many people might die if states
open too quickly.
It's a big number and those documents have
now leaked.
Of course, the Trump administration is not
talking publicly about any of this.
So when we ask the question how many people
will die of coronavirus, there is not one
answer.
A, we have modeling their confidence intervals.
The death toll depends on things that we can't
control, like how contagious is coronavirus?
What is the bottom line?
Death rate.
The fatality rate of the virus.
The death toll also depends on things we can
control, like social distancing, whether we
open states too early, whether we find a treatment
or a vaccine.
Now, publicly, the Trump administration has
taken the approach of claiming that the baseline,
if he did nothing, would have been 2.2 million
deaths.
Trump often says, I could have done nothing
and to 2.2 million people would have died,
but I've done stuff.
So we're gonna be way below that now.
No president could really get away with doing
nothing.
Once you start mitigation, the possible death
toll starts to decline.
One model said could be one hundred and fifty
to two hundred and fifty thousand.
Another said could be one to two hundred thousand.
And eventually, as more and more governors
closed down, projections kept improving, down
to roughly 60 to 70 thousand deaths for wave
one in which we are right now.
The wave one thing is important because more
and more medical experts think there will
be a second wave of the virus starting in
the fall, possibly a third wave in 2021.
OK, let's put that aside for now.
The important question now is, after going
through weeks of mitigation, what would happen
if we reopen states too early?
We had a record single day death toll this
week.
We are have very high numbers of deaths.
We are still finding 25000 or more new cases
every single day in the United States.
We're hopefully in the peak.
The peak is a plateau.
It can last a month or so.
If we do everything right.
So when Texas and Georgia and other states
plan to reopen tomorrow and Monday and other
days next week, it's very risky.
Now, Trump was asked a few days ago.
Are you worried about a resurgence in the
virus if states open too quickly?
Have you modeled what those numbers would
look like?
And Trump said, if we did nothing, we would
have lost 2 million people.
Now we won't.
The truth, though, is we know that they do
have models about what happens if they open
too early and they're really, really bad.
Before we look at the models, here's Trump's
answer when he was asked about this a few
days ago.
Thank you.
Has the government modeled the possibility
that there is a widespread resurgence if this
just doesn't work?
How many deaths?
So if we didn't do what we did.
We were talking about up to 2.2 million deaths.
So that's five times almost what we lost in
the civil war.
Okay.
If if everything happens properly and if we
continue to go the way we're going now, we
will be significantly less than the lowest
number with mitigation.
So we'll be significantly less.
And it's still a lot of people.
Now, Trump, first of all, didn't answer saying
if I did nothing, we would have 2.2 million
deaths.
The question was, have you modeled what would
happen if you open too early?
The answer is a simple yes.
And we have those models.
Trump gave that ridiculous answer on April
17th, but in early April, the federal government
put together models of what happens if social
distancing stops too quickly and the numbers
are anywhere from a middle of the road.
Guess of 300000 thousand deaths all the way
up to 1.8 million deaths.
This is a model from the Department of Health
and Human Services.
Trump's administration had the data in early
April, but Trump gave a bogus answer.
We now have their models and they are very
concerning.
The Department of HHS has four scenarios and
then they have like a best guess, which is
in the middle.
The models range from 94000 deaths, up to
1.8 million deaths.
Trump likes to say thanks to me, we'll have
60000 deaths instead of 2.2 million.
It's absurd, but thanks to opening too early,
you could have 1.8 million deaths instead
of 60000.
The best scenario, expect 94000 deaths.
There are some in-between models up all the
way up to one which they pegged at 1.8 million
deaths.
And then you have a sort of average of these
a best guess right now, which says if you
open to early, about 300000 people are going
to die.
So there are multiple things to think about
here.
First, Trump was asked, have you modeled this?
And he didn't answer.
It's possible he saw this model, but he won't
admit it.
That's a problem of dishonesty.
It's possible he didn't even see it.
That's a problem of Trump often not having
the facts because he lacks the attention span
to actually absorb that information.
Number two, if Trump wants to take credit
for 60K instead of 2 million, he would have
to take responsibility for 300K K or a million
or 1.8 million instead of 60k.
If it's a result of states opening to early
thanks to his public posturing about opening
up the economy over the last 24 hours, he
has finally said, you know, I think maybe
George is opening up too early and it's possible
someone got to him and said, you can't be
on the side of encouraging this because it's
going to be really bad.
But the most important takeaway is the government
has the data.
They know the risks and they have the numbers.
And yet Trump and Fox News have mostly still
been fomenting these freedom and liberty protests
around the country from people just demanding
that governors let it rip.
People will die.
We now know that they know it.
And the next thing I want to talk.
About is the astro turfed protesters that
we have seen